The title of today's webinar is Using BLAST
Well.
I'm please to present Tom Madden who is the
lead of our BLAST team here at NCBI.
I'm going to turn it over to Tom Madden now.
Thank you Peter.
This is Tom Madden, and let me give a little
bit of background on this webinar.
This was originally written this up as a talk
for a Hackathon we had at the NIH about a
month ago.
It was well received, and then we had other
ideas.
We modified this a bit and we're using the
webinar to share those ideas.
Since it was for a Hackathon it was centered
around and targeted to standalone BLAST-plus
users as opposed to people who come to the
web page to run BLAST.
If you have never run standalone BLAST let
me first say what that is.
basically that means you download our executables
from the FTP site and then you go to a command
line and type something to run them.
I will have examples later on.
If you have never done that you may still
find this interesting because I will talk
about some of the BLAST databases and what
they contain.
Let me get going.
Hopefully you will find this interesting.
This is the first what I call the boilerplate
slide.
What is blast.
Most people are familiar with the basics of
what BLAST is supposed to do.
The main idea is that it calculates similarity
for biological sequences, and you get your
query and scan a database and look for similar
sequences.
You can decide whether or not those similar
sequences are homologous.
It's pretty fast, and it uses statistical
theory to help you determine whether it occurred
by chance.
So, first I'm going to talk about the different
databases that we have.
Our database descriptions can actually be
kind of confusing, this is something that
we need to work on in as maybe doing a better
job of this.
There are two main databases that people often
use.
One is the non-redundant protein database,
called NR, which is the largest collection
of proteins.
It gives you proteins from GenBank CDSs and
PDB and SwissProt, which will give you everything
though it excludes proteins from environmental
samples from WGS and it also excludes patents
sequences.
Those are searchable separately in separate
databases.
And the other database that a lot of people
search is the nucleotide (nt) one.
And that has a lot of collections nucleotides.
It does exclude some of these like ESTs, GSS,
WGS, and a whole bunch of other sequences.
It excludes assembled genomes like the human
genome and mouse genome.
And that is something that you can search
separately.
And it's important to realize what is in these
databases as you go looking at them.
It can be confusing.
One way to look at this is a Venn diagram.
Pictures worth a 1000 words.
Venn diagram is worth 10,000.
What we have on the left here, (Peter can
they see my mouse?)
I guess you can see my mouse.
This large circle is NR nonredundant database,
inside of NR, it includes a few other databases
which is a RefSeq protein which are sequences
that have been annotated here at the NCBI.
A little bit more validation has been done
on them.
Also included is Swissprot sequences, if you
are familiar with SwissProt that is a smaller
database which are also very well curated.
Inside the RefSeq protein is the landmark
database, which we use for SmartBLAST, and
that is a set from proteomes from 26 different
organisms, which gives you a nonredundant
spread out set.
On top of that is PDB, those are sequences
associated with PDB structures.
The size [of the Venn diagram circles] is
not really to scale.
More to give you an idea of what things are.
RefSeq is about half of NR, so it is very
large.
I just threw this here [SwissProt circle].
A lot of the sequences in Swissprot do overlap
with RefSeq, and maybe they overlap 100%,
I'm not sure.
I do know that landmark is completely enclosed
with RefSeq.
The other independent databases: there are
Metagenomic proteins.
And basically a lot of these come from WGS,
the transcriptome shotgun assembly proteins
and patents.
Before I move on, let's say, NR has 171,000,000
sequences and 63,000,000,000 residues.
it is pretty large.
RefSeq is 118 million sequences and 45,000,000,000
residues so RefSeq is a substantial fraction
of NR.
Swissprot has 470,000 sequences and 178,000,000
residues.
Landmark as I show you here is very small.
One question is why do I search these and
you can think of this like a use case.
Why would people want to run a search against
NR, as opposed to RefSeq protein or landmark.
The way to think about NR, the nonredundant
one, is it's almost all of the proteins at
the NCBI.
You might be looking for homologs and other
organisms, you want to look for protein in
other organisms.
Or maybe you just want to identify your protein.
I don't know what my protein is and I'll search
it against the NCBI.
RefSeq protein is basically the same task,
you have well curated proteins in RefSeq,
and there you might search for homologs in
other organisms and you might just identify
a protein.
On the other hand, Landmark, has got only
26, or 23, different organisms spread across
a great taxonomic range.
That will allow you to find homologs in distally-related
model organisms that represents a wide range
of taxonomic groups.
These are not necessarily all of the use cases
you can have for a database, and if you're
not doing this, it doesn't mean that you are
doing something wrong.
If you would like to share in the [question]
box what you are doing with the protein or
nucleotide databases, and we have time to
go through those, and that might be useful
for people to hear how these databases are
being used.
It might be interesting for me too.
[The slide] says at the bottom it is not an
exhaustive list.
Moving on to the nucleotide databases, it's
a lot more confusing in a way.
Now here you have the nucleotide, I talked
about earlier.
This is 48 million sequences and 200 billion
bases.
This is substantial.
Inside of it is the RefSeq RNA, and that's
23 million sequence and 57 billion bases,
about a third of the NT.
Then we have the smaller 16S ribosomal sequences,
I will come back to tell you what these are
for, but the 16S is well curated sequences
that you can actually use, to verify the taxonomy
for your sequences.
We have this group on the left.
And then over here [on the right side of the
slide] we have this massive set which is RefSeq
genomes, which basically all of the genomes
that are in the RefSeq at NCBI.
That's going to include most of the eukaryotic
genomes, Human genomes, mouse genomes, and
many other genomes, also will have alligator
genome, crocodile genome, so this ends up
being a very large set.
Within a set of RefSeq genomes, we have what
is called representative genomes, and that
gives you, rather than giving you all redundant
sets of genomes, it gives you the one best
genome we think if representative and so that
would mean that rather than having three copies
of this human genome, and there's probably
more than that now, that you just have the
one in the representative genome set.
Outside of this is other things like express
sequence tags, ESTs, patent, again, we've
separated out the patent again, the rationale
for that is, most scientists are not interested
in seeing the patent record, they don't have
a lot of scientific information on them.
If you are really interested in patents, then
you're probably not going to be interested
in all of these other sequences over here.
There are other older sets of databases like
high throughput genome sequences, phases O,1,2.
These were really popular about 20 years ago
when the human genome was being assembled
and since then, you don't really get any additions
to HTGS or EST anymore, and to my thinking,
they aren't that interesting because they
will not have the newest sequence.
On top of that we have the BLAST through the
webpage, and through the standalone executables
offers you the whole genome sequences and
I cannot even tell you how large that is,
it is very large, as well as SRA, which is
the NCBI sequence read archive.
So at least I know for SRA they measure this
and talk about petabytes and peta-bases, WGS
is also not small.
Again let's look at some of the use cases
for the nucleotide Databases.
And what we see people doing with NT, this
is the largest database.
Now maybe they're going to verify the identity
of the DNA, let me, I just sequenced something,
I think I know what it is and I just want
to verify it real quick.
I might have the case that I really need to
identify the DNA.
I've done some sequencing runs, I have a lot
of DNA, and I want to run to see each of these
sequences are part of.
So RefSeq RNA as it says here, implies that
these are RNAs, mRNAs and other RNAs, curated,
provided by the RefSeq group at NCBI, for
this, you can identify unknown mRNA transcripts,
you could identify coding regions and genomic
sequences, and you could look for other RNA
types of sequence.
16S Database, that I talked about, this is
very useful because it allows you to classify
the taxonomy of the samples, and this data
has been maintained at the NCBI, so we are
pretty sure the taxonomy.
We think this is pretty reliable.
It also allows you to validate the quality
of the sequences, for example, look for misassembly
or contaminations or such.
Finally, there's these other sequences we
talk about, like the human genome.
The question might be, when should I use NT,
or when should I use the human genome?
For the human genome case, this is when I
have a gene, and I want to find a specific
gene on a specific genome, which would be
for blastn or tblastn.
Blastn, which would take a nucleotide query
and blast it against the human genome.
Actually, I'm sorry, TBLASTN doesn't apply
here that's wrong.
And the other case is I might map reads to
a new genome, with a new program that we call
Magic-BLAST, which is splice aware aligner.
I will mention that later on.
As I mentioned before, NT is pretty large,
about 200 billion bases, RefSeq RNA is about
57 billion bases, and the 16S is about 30
million bases, so the other two are 'b's and
16S is an 'm'.
And the human genome stays at about 3 billion
bases.
If we go up here [pointing to the RefSeq genome
circle], just to be clear, this RefSeq genome
here is 1.2 tera bases.
I guess that is trillion bases, so that is
really very large.
Now I want to switch gears and I've gone over
the databases and switch gears and talk about
BLAST parameters.
This is something that people have found confusing
in the past.
And will probably find confusing in the future.
This is why I want to address it.
There are a large number of blast parameters
and a lot of them have to do with some sort
of algorithm tuning.
Most of those you can leave alone and they
have been tuned for a good default.
So I would not, most of those I would not
change.
Also, on the standalone [blast], there is
this 'task' parameter that you can set.
So by the 'task' parameter, targets your search
to a specific use case.
For example -task of blastn gives you a word
size of 11, and a pretty sensitive search,
whereas -task of MegaBLAST, invokes the greedy
megablast alignment and that has an initial
word size of 28, which means I need an exact
match 28 letters before I would do anything
and then uses a greedy method of extension.
Generally speaking, it is faster but less
sensitive but often does the job.
On blastp, you do a -task of blastp, which
is the standard blastp search that people
have known about for quite a while, first
coming out in [19]97.
Then there is also -task blastp-fast, which
is still pretty sensitive but uses a larger
word size and a compressed alphabet to do
the search actually faster.
That is actually a good way to approach the
problems by setting the dash[-] task flag,
and there are other parameters that I would
encourage people look at.
For example, there is the expect value.
If you are not familiar with an expect value,
I will tell you real quick what it is.
Generally, an expect value, lower is better.
That means a lower expect value is better,
like a P value, the lower the better it is.
It is, the default, think of a false positive
rate.
The number of hits equal to or greater than
the score expected to arise by chance.
If that last sentence is a little long to
remember, just think that lower is better,
false positive rate.
The default now is 10.
which is actually a little high for searches,
it says if you have an expect value of 10,
you probably have 10 results in there that
just arose by chance.
Often you want to lower the expect value to
0.01, or 10 to the -5 or 10 to the minus 30,
it really depends on what you will do to the
results.
If you want to make sure you get a lot of
results, in that you have to comb through
stuff, maybe think about what people call
the twilight zone, where it's not really clear
whether this is a real homolog, or some kind
of artefact, then maybe you want to go to
zero point one or 0.01.
On the other hand, if you have a pipeline,
and you want to make sure that these are really
strong matches, and you have hundreds or thousands
of millions of sequences, you probably want
to have a really low expect value to prevent
you from having false positives.
Okay, so other parameters that you want to
look at.
Things like word size, and I had mentioned
this before in the task [parameter], BLASTn
default is 11.
That means that you need 11 bases that match
exactly.
Before you do anything between two sequences,
the two sequences need to have 11 bases matching
exactly, and for MegaBLAST that is 28, which
makes megablast less sensitive but the databases
as we talked about are actually pretty big
so a megablast search with 28, a lot of mRNAs,
you'll probably get a fair number of hits
and you may get all the information you may
need.
If you're running the, getting the standard
report, you can change the number of descriptions,
as in the number of alignments.
You can also change the, what we call max_target_seqs,
and the tabular, XML, or JSON [formats].
I'll be showing you examples of these formats
in a little bit.
But before I do that.
I want to go back and talk about something
people have been discussing recently on Twitter
and other places.
So I have my search here, right, and I am
running blastn and the default task for blastn,
this is really a MegaBLAST run, and I'm running
against NT, these 200 billion bases, and I've
got my query, it's part of an E.coli sequence.
I set a low set value, 10 to the -6.
I just want to see one match, max_target_seqs
is 1.
I want to see the first hit that BLAST finds,
this is a way of getting tabular output, so
I can say '-outfmt', so I want to see the
query accession, the database accession, the
start and the end of the database sequence,
the expect value of the match, the scientific
name and title.
We have some documentation on this and I'll
go through other examples of this 'outfmt'
here.
But the main thing is, if you run it, you
get one match, you've asked BLAST to give
you one match.
It gives you that.
I named this query E.coli, this is the accession
of the database sequence.
So what we have here.
This just says the match starts here at 3.9
million [3961744], and then goes on to here
[3959157].
It has an expect value of basically zero which
means just below ten to the minus 180.
Very small.
A large bit score which means it is high.
The organism is E. coli, and the title is
isolate NQ3 chromosome complete genome.
Okay, very good.
So I put this in here.
I got one E.coli match, this is the only best
result, but let's go back and look at this
run down here.
I've done the same run except rather than
asking max_target_seqs [-] 1, I say max_target_seqs
10, I want to see 10 matches, this gives me
more to look at.
But maybe it's a little bit more revealing,
and it depends upon what I want, and I'm seeing
my 10 matches, the interesting thing here,
is that, this is the max target sequence,
and I actually have five matches with the
same score, they are all equivalent and really
there is no way to say one is better than
the other as far as BLAST is concerned.
These are all E. coli.
Maybe that doesn't make any difference to
you, depending on your use case.
This is E.coli and I'm happy with that.
there may be other examples where we could
find one of the E.coli strains that is pathogenic,
or maybe it matches exactly with some other
bacteria.
So that's a question.
By looking at the first one, You are actually
throwing away some of this information.
Here you see that there are basically different
strains are listed here.
You've lost that information by only looking
at one.
Of course, it depends on what you are looking
to do with this, whether you can be satisfied
with just one, or maybe you want to go for
a few and double check that.
This is actually kind of the dangers of looking
at just one match.
Now switching gears a little bit.
I want to talk about different types of reports
that you can produce.
Since this talk is geared towards standalone
BLAST plus, I'm going to go through different
reports that are easier to parse and that
people might find useful when they are running
BLAST.
Especially as part of a pipeline.
The first one here is a standard BLAST report.
It's been around for a long time.
This actually is the command line that produces
this BLAST report, you see the blastn, the
database is refseq_rna, the query is U0001,
I put it in fasta here, and I'm just taking
the first 40 lines here.
If you are familiar with unix or linux, 'head'
just means give me the first 40 lines [note:
10 is default, -# is a specific number of
lines], I'm taking the first 40 lines here.
We see a reference [to blast related publication],
we see the name of the database, the query
and what the query is, the length of the query
and these different matches that are produced,
significant alignments, statistically significant,
the bit score is over here.
And there you see the E value, and you notice
that all these E values that are coming up
are zero, just because there are a lot of
different copies of this mRNA in refseq_rna
database.
Even though this is running in megablast node
here, there is absolutely no problem of finding
lots of results.
This report is designed to be human readable,
it is subject to change.
And we do not encourage you to parse it, and
that's actually why we produce some other
formats that are easier to parse and provide
better support for that.
One that people actually like a lot is the
so-called tabular report, here is a command
line, which shows you how to run this.
To produce this output, we use -outfmt 7,
it's going to give me the default tabular
report, which is the query and subject, and
the percent identity, and some other information
you can look at.
The main thing being, here you have the expect
value which you saw on the normal blast report,
and here you have the bit scores, and it gives
you the start and stop of the matches, and
so if you could go through and parse this
and say, Oh, well, my query matched these
database sequences starting here to there.
Maybe I will pick this out and go look at
it some more.
This is simple to parse, it is nice.
Now if this is not all the information people
ever want, out of BLAST, that's why we have
a customized tabular report.
To do that it's -outfmt seven and quer accession
[qaccver], subject accession [saccver], length,
the length of the alignment, and this is the
subject length.
This is giving you pretty basic information,
it is not giving you the expect value, it's
not giving you the bit score, so you see here
this is quer all the time, these are the different
database sequences.
These are the lengths of the database sequences.
I'm sorry, these are the lengths of the alignment
[third column] and then these are the lengths
of the database sequences.
For example, you can write an auk script that
will parse this and you can take and divide
this length by that length, to tell you how
much of your subject sequence was covered
by your query.
Or how much of your subject sequences was
actually covered by the alignment, maybe you
want matches that cover most of the subject
sequence.
Something else you can do is to go for taxonomy.
So this is the same thing here.
Query accession, subject accession, the scientific
name, and then the common name and that's
for the subject sequence in both cases, and
so you see here this is Homo sapiens, human,
this is pygmy chimpanzee, and this gives you
taxonomy information without telling you,
you're not looking at expect value or bit
score here, but you could print those out
here but I didn't bother to keep it simple.
This gives you specialized taxonomy information.
For the same thing, CSV, comma separated value,
you should be able to upload it, pull it into
Excel or parse it in some other way.
That gives you a lot of flexibility.
Something else that people have liked, has
been the JSON, I think of this as a blast
report in JSON.
And here for example you see the reference
up here, see some of the parameter information,
the query ID, if you go down here, you're
seeing the information about your first match.
You have the ID, the accession.
Nine 606 means it's human, so the taxid, the
NCBI Taxonomy group assigns a taxid to every
node in the taxonomy tree, and for human it
is 9606.
That's just a convenient way of referring,
at least in programs of referring back to
a specific node in a taxonomy tree.
This is actually giving you a lot of information
here in an easily parseable way, in JSON from
a Python script, load it in, and parse this
out pretty quickly.
Basically we have XML format that is the same
thing.
One comment, you may know we are the NCBI,
is moving away from gi's and towards accessions,
I suggest that you stick with the accessions
here rather than being stuck in the gi's that
may disappear from you.
Oh, sorry, this is the outfmt 15 and the command
line here.
I showed you a bunch of different reports.
You could imagine they have different uses.
For example, I run blast, I want to get a
tabular report, and I only want to look at
matches that cover my query, only have a certain
coverage of my query, or maybe have a certain
taxonomy.
Or a certain bit score.
If they reach some threshold, maybe I want
to go back and look at this manually, otherwise
I will just discard this.
So, this would almost indicate that you need
to run BLAST multiple times, but that is actually
not the case.
Can BLAST has something that you can run it
once, and then you can enjoy your results,
so to speak, many times with the blast_formatter.
This is an example, this is the command line
I would run for blastn, and this is the database
refseq_rna, and the query, output format 11,
and it produces BLAST archived format.
The blast_formatter is a separate program,
can read in this file here, and it can format
it as requested, for example, this is outfmt
7, the standard tabular format, basically
all of these examples I showed you earlier.
So you could, run this one right here, and
if you decided that the length of the alignment
was long enough, and overcame some threshold,
and thought that was interesting to look at,
you could go down and look and spit out a
BLAST report.
And that gives you a lot of flexibility.
Shifting gear again.
Hopefully I'm not doing too bad on time, and
I want to talk about taxonomic limits, it
can clear the clutter, meaning I got a lot
of results and I don't want to see them all,
maybe I only want to see the human results
or maybe I don't want to see the human results,
maybe I only want to see bacterial results,
and it runs faster.
In general at least, because you have less
of a database to search.
Here is an example, I've got RefSeq protein,
this human protein which I am searching against
refseq_protein, limited to human.
I see then all of these, well first, all these
matches say human here.
You will see I have different components,
different isoforms.
I have a lot of variety.
These two proteins are related.
But I'm getting all the different isoforms.
This is all the results I get, I get 12 results.
That is actually great, because I can actually
look through those if I'm interested in different
isoforms, then now I have that information.
If I do the same thing without a limit.
You know first of all it's 507 hits, you're
not seeing all the hits here.
I'm seeing it from different organisms.
From gorilla and chimp and everything else.
What is different here also is I'm really
only seem to be seeing one version of the
protein.
One isoform here.
They all say component A2.
This is actually a different use case.
I've got one protein, one isoform, I want
to see how it appears in all kinds of different
organisms.
Maybe I want to make a tree with this, maybe
I want to find out, if this isoform which
organisms it appears in.
That is a different use case.
Recently we have made enhancements to help
people with this search by taxonomy, we are
calling this BLASTDBv5, I apologize for the
programmer speak, and the reason why it's
called version 5 is the current version of
blast database [BLASTDB] is version 4, but
what it lets you do is limit your search by
taxonomy with a command line parameter, and
the taxonomy information is built into the
database in a way that we can use it to limit
your search.
The other thing about BLASTDBv5 is it improves
your performance when limiting a blast search
with accessions or retrieving by accession
and this is important as the NCBI moves from
gi's which are numbers to accessions.
You can also retrieve sequences by taxonomy
from the blast database, and it works with
the newest version of BLAST plus which was
made in an alpha release several months but
we're going to have an upcoming release in
hopefully this month.
Peter did a webinar on this, several months
ago, there is a YouTube link here and documentation
that you can get to.
Since these slides are available, you can
get to those.
So moving on here.
I will tell you a little bit about Magic-BLAST,
it's a splice aware aligner, it's based on
the aligner in the magic pipeline that Jean
and Danielle Thierry-Mieg had made and we
re-implemented that with a BLAST toolkit.
It uses blast databases to do its mapping.
It's especially good with longer sequences,
and we have an article actually, we have a
preprint in bio-archive [bioRxiv.org], that
we'll be submitting to a journal soon, so
this is a figure from that preprint, and this
is a set we made up.
The reads are based on the RefSeq annotation,
and so that we know what the results really
should be like.
Magic-BLAST was not used in the RefSeq annotation
so it is not a circular logic here.
But you can see with Magic-BLAST for these
longer sequences here, we do pretty well,
perfect matches is 97.2% and some partial
and some misaligned.
We're comparing this to the HISAT2 with relaxed
parameters, HISAT2, STAR long and the older
TopHat2.
Real quick, because I think I've probably
run out of my time, you can see the URL at
the top [of the slide], you can download standalone
BLAST down at the bottom there, and over here
in the right corner, you can see where there
is help you can get.
And we also have AMI, you know an Amazon Machine
Image, in an AWS image that you can run, and
which you can get it from there.
Resources, some of the resources for command
line options, and these are actually the appendices
in the BLAST manual, and so this is several
tables of the command line options that you
can go and look at them.
There is another appendix that reward mismatch
penalties and that applies to blastn and megaBLAST,
available scoring matrices, and this is more
BLASTp, blastX, and then there's a link to
the Magic-BLAST article.
After this is a few more slides I will not
go into, that's an appendix that I call the
hidden life of the BLAST database, but we
didn't have time for that but if you're wanting
to take a look at, then you're welcome to
do that.
[Peter] This is Peter Cooper again, we have
a lot of questions.
More than I've ever seen in a webinar before
to be hone with you, which is good.
Many of these are detailed questions about
how do I do a particular task.
I think I can't even answer those because
I would have to go and look at certain things
to give you the correct, exact, Entrez queries
and things like that.
For those things, I've answered some of them
in the chat [window], but I haven't been able
to answer all of them.
I will make a document with the answers to
those.
I'll post that and pass it off to everybody.
One thing that has come up several times,
because it was announced several times ahead
of time, Tom might be able to discuss this
a little more was the max target sequence
letter that was in Bioinformatics.
So there has been a lot of confusion.
I guess, there's several questions in chat
pod about that, and people want to know what
is the effective max target sequence, and
what's the recommendation for how they should
use that parameter?
How does it affect what results they see back?
In other words, it's clear from reading the
questions, that many people believe it will
show you the first match it finds rather than
the best one, which I don't think is true.
But I will let you address that, if you don't
mind.
[Tom] So, thanks, Peter.
So BLAST goes through the database, looking
for the best matches, collects those, and
then presents them to you.
I kind of, can I go back here.
This is starting to address here, 'Limiting
output to one match' [slide] so what BLAST
does, it goes through your database, finds
the best matches, ranks them by score and
expect value, in this case, in the bottom
set, there are five matches that are basically
equivalent, and BLAST can't say that one is
better than the other.
It does show you, the user, if you say you
only want to see one, it will show you the
top one.
Even if you say, I only want to see one, blast
is still going to go through the entire database,
it's still going to collect these five matches.
It actually collects a few more matches, actually,
many more matches than it presents to you
because, and this is just part of the algorithm
to make sure that we don't miss stuff.
Or to make it very unlikely that we miss stuff.
There had been the question, max target sequences
is 1, when I think about it, generally I would
recommend that you probably want to look at
more than one sequence, again it depends on
your use case, in this case I have 10, and
I saw a bunch that were the same.
Maybe if you don't want to look at a lot,
then 10 is a good number.
I would probably shy away from one unless
you have a case like, any hit at all, that
you are only interested if there is any match
at all, and so something that comes to my
mind, maybe people have other examples, would
be say I done some bacterial sequencing, I
know the results should be bacterial, but
they've been done by humans, and I want to
make sure that there is no human DNA involved
in there, that I didn't contaminate it somehow
with my own DNA, I take my sequences and I
run these sequences against the human database,
and any match is going to be disqualifying
for this read, for this query and I will just
throw it away because it is contamination.
That's an example I think maybe where max
target sequence is one would be okay, but
generally you want to go through several,
and like Peter said, there is some confusion
about how BLAST goes through the database.
It does go through all the database, collects
all matches, and there is an example that
you could, and in this letter that he mentioned,
there wasn't the example that I really wanted
to see.
I kind of need to see the command line parameters
and such, you can imagine, you take all these
sequences, I reorder them and maybe BLAST
will give me a different top match but maybe
if I were to take my database and reorder
it, maybe I would get the second match here
instead of the first one.
It is the same significance.
Blast does have some tie-breaking logic in
it, to help people, that is getting into the
technical details again, basically my point
of view when I think about it and I hadn't
thought about it until the last week, is max_target_seqs
equal 1 is not really a great choice.
[Peter] okay, thanks, Tom, will you put that
last slide back up?
Just because.
The last slide in the deck, we are basically
out of time, there are lots of good questions.
I want to point out on the last slide, there
are useful links, people were asking me stuff
about command line parameters and things like
that.
Those things are addressed in the manual or
in the help docs so take a look there, and
if you ever have a question, like many that
came in the chat pod, write to BLAST help
Blast help is an address that is on the slide
here, that's blast-help@ncbi.nlm.nih.gov and
we will answer your question.
I just couldn't get to all of the ones we
got in the questions pod today, but I will
put those in a document, and I will make them
available and send out a link to it as soon
as I have it ready.
I want to thank everybody for coming, it's
about quarter to one which is, we said this
was a 45 minute webinar, so we're going to
stop there, and thanks everyone and we'll
see you next time.